okay important news here the FDA has
announced that while they're claiming
anyway that drinking bleach won't cure
cancer or autism at which you know
that's what I have to say to that I've
been drinking bleach bleach for years
and I don't have cancer so what I mean
what what other proof do you need
sure my internal organs sometimes leak
out of my nose but I mean that's that's
just part of growing up that's part of
getting older
to clarify kids that is a joke
definitely don't drink bleach I had no
idea that drinking bleach to cure
disease was a thing apparently it is
definitely don't do that I'm not sure
why we needed the FDA to announce this I
guess maybe next they'll announce that
you know drinking out of a public toilet
won't cure diabetes I mean there are a
lot of things that won't cure things so
it's just general general advice there
all right let's some let's look at the
latest briefly here in the Epstein case
before we move on we're now being told
that Epstein was found and this was the
the news last night he was found hanging
with a sheet a bedsheet around his neck
they say that he tied the sheet to the
top of a bunk bed made a noose and then
somehow hung himself that way now it's a
little hard to picture I guess because
Epstein was what six feet tall and the
bunk I mean how talk of the bunk bed
have been could have been I mean that's
it's a jail so I'm assuming this isn't a
20 foot tall bunk beds so but that's
that's what they say that's how they say
they found him this is still confusing
for a number of reasons first of all
there was a former inmate at this
particular prison who came out couple
days ago and said that but he said that
it was impossible that Epstein could
have killed himself in his opinion
because there would be no way to do what
he said that the the sheets the bed
sheets are like paper-thin so you
wouldn't be able to it would break if
you tried to use it for that purpose
though this guy didn't factor in a bunk
bed I you know he was imagining a cell
without a bunk bed but this had a bunk
bed and that's the other thing that
doesn't make sense is you've got the
most important inmates in the federal
in your custody the most important
inmate because of the testimony he could
provide and he's attempted suicide
before supposedly and so then you leave
him alone with a bedsheet and a bunk bed
I mean and you don't check on him for
hours that just makes no sense to me
so I have a feeling that the latest
report here will not do much to quell
the conspiracy theories especially
because nobody has any faith in our
governing institutions like we talked
about yesterday nobody trusts anything
they tell us and so that's that's also
gonna make it not much better but it's
still it just doesn't make any sense
if considering even if he wasn't
important because of the testimony even
if even if this was just an average
ordinary federal prison inmate the fact
that he's attempted suicide recently
Sallee it was two years ago he's
attempted suicide in the last month and
you leave him with a bedsheet in a bunk
bed it that doesn't really make any
sense to me at all all right now let's
let's take a look at this as we move on
quickly CNN anchor Chris Cuomo
was out I think to dinner with his
family couple nights ago when somebody
decided to heckle him and secretly
record his Cuomo's reaction there's
video which I'll play for you in a
second
but of course the video only shows
Cuomo's reaction it doesn't show what
was said to him so we should always we
should always keep that in mind when you
see video like this and you're only
seeing one sigh it picks up in the
middle of the conversation and somebody
is reacting to something anytime you see
a video that begins with a person's
reaction to something but you don't see
what they're reacting to that should
make you that should be a red flag so he
but we know that whatever this guy said
to Cuomo to set him off it included
calling him Fredo and Fredo of course is
that one of the brothers and the
Godfather kind of the flunky stupid
brother who gets passed over to become
the Godfather in
in favor of Michael Michael and then
eventually spoiler alert afraid I was
killed by Michael Corleone at the end of
the second movie which in as far as I'm
concerned the end of the second movie is
the end of the Godfather series because
Godfather three doesn't exist in my my
truth is that Godfather three doesn't
exist anyway Cuomo didn't take too
kindly to this bit of mockery and so
here's how that unfolded
now judging by social media a lot of
conservatives are giving Cuomo a hard
time about this painting him as the bad
guy in the situation acting offended
like a bunch of wilting little flowers
traumatized by the fact that Cuomo and
used bad language oh use pad language he
threatened violence oh my goodness I've
never seen such a thing I'm so
traumatized they've got their fans out
and they're fanning of it that's that's
how good it right right a lot of white
right-wingers on social media right now
that's I imagine them I imagine him
typing in the other hand they've got a
fan and they're Fanning themself that
depicts that prevent themselves from
fainting the cages they just can't
believe the language the language used
they're also you know they're people
acting offended that Cuomo claimed Fredo
is an ethnic slur against Italians and
obviously that is absurd Fredo is is not
an ethnic slur de is a pert it's an
insult yeah it's a personal insult
usually used against someone who is
considered the dumb or weak one in the
family so if you're called if someone's
calling you Fredo they're not making any
reference to you being Italian because
you could that's an insult that can be
used whether you're Italian or not what
they're just to be clear just so you
know how you're being insulted what
they're saying is that you are the dumb
weak irrelevant one in the family that's
just so you know what they're saying
about you see that's what Fredo doesn't
refer to Italian heritage it refers to
family dynamics so Cuomo obviously was
wrong to call it an ethnic slur of
course with that said I firmly believe
and have always believed and have always
said that heckling a public figure and
secretly recording their reaction to try
and get clicks is a punk move it is a
move an absolute punk move and I hate it
I really hate it I don't care who the
target is okay to me the politics of it
don't matter I just absolutely hate it
to eat Oh to harass this guy Boise
I mean he's not doing anything to you
okay you don't like his show you think
he's about biased Newsday okay all right
whatever who cares he's out with his
family and you come up to him and start
and start mouthing off you know the guy
filming it deserved to be treated
exactly as he was treated and again the
Pope I don't see how the politics matter
here this is just man-to-man right and
that's what Cuomo thought this was he
didn't realize he was being filmed he
didn't he didn't realize this was this
was a this was a you know a bit that was
gonna end up on YouTube he thought this
was man-to-man and that's how he was
treating him say look man-to-man you
know you need to back down and I respect
Cuomo more for that I guess I'm in the
mind I'm apparently in a small minority
I respect him more after seeing that my
respect actually went up I didn't have a
lot of respect before I still don't have
a ton but it's it has the respect at
least has has gone that you know has
gone in the upward direction on the on
the bar graph
yeah the ethnic slur thing was dumb but
but whatever he didn't make that wasn't
a public claim that he was making he
didn't know he was being reported the
main point is that Cuomo manda be
handled his business he called the troll
out on his crap and he made the troll
back down and I respect that look trolls
are accustomed to being loudmouth jerks
online and running their mouths to
whoever they want saying whatever they
want without repercussion that's what
trolls online are used to doing I mean
they're there they are weak spineless
cowards and on the rare occasion that a
troll tries that garbage face-to-face
with someone I am always happy to see
them slap down for it rhetorically maybe
even physically a
because I I just think you treat someone
like that you deserve what comes man to
man you deserve it now as I said a lot
of people on the right are acting
scandalized by this but we all know
here's the thing
again man to man or man to woman
whoever's whoever you are watching this
right now if you're a conservative all
right look just we don't need to lie to
each other we can be honest all right
there's no it's just me and you there's
no one else here except for all the
other people watching but let's be
honest with you we know if that was a
Fox News host then you would be
defending it so if you're pretending to
be outraged by it or offended or though
that was way overboard
I mean oh yes so to respond is okay but
to threaten violence well that's just
that's just going too far you know you
wouldn't be saying that if this was
tucker carlson in fact there was a video
of tucker carlson responding in a
similar way to someone who was heckling
him and with that I I took Tucker
Carlson side I said yeah we he desert
okay yeah he could you're coming at a
man when he's out with his family this
isn't the internet anymore you punk I
mean if you come to someone like that
you this is this is how you might get
treated don't go crying about it
be a man and then they don't put a video
online and say look at what this mean
man said to me just stop that man up so
with with Tucker Carlson I said I'm
fully on board were talking opossum from
what I remember he forget all the
details of that but he he was using foul
language and good for him you know good
for him but again as I conserved if
you're pretending to be offended by this
or whatever with Tucker Carlson you
defended that I know you did and if this
was Sean Hannity or
I mean if this was if this was Donald
Trump who was caught on video it take
that exact video everything the same I
mean the Fredo comment would make less
sense because Trump's not Italian and
but take that video everything's the
same but it's but it's Trump
caught on camera responding to a heckler
that way or in fact forget about that if
he was on if he was on stage in front of
millions responding to a heckler like
that you would be applauding it and you
know you would you and I both know that
ok you don't need to lie to me or lie to
yourself so this is a double standard
and this is what I just can't when we
all you know when there's a double
standard and people are doing this
performative fake outrage thing you know
we all know that it's fake so I the
performative the performative ly
outraged mob how do they when they're
when they're all looking at each other
like they all know that they're faking
it that they don't really care and that
if this was someone else they'd be
defending it so let's just let's just
cut let's just let's just cut the crap
it's so boring it's so I'm so bored by
it I'm so that's the main thing it's not
even my main problem is not even an
ethical problem although there's that
because it's dishonest but my main thing
is I'm just so bored I mean everything
that happens I know exactly what
everyone's gonna say depending okay
what's the politics or whose side is
this guy on okay let's pretend if she's
just stop already
this was a man he's this is this is how
two men always threaten violence that's
how that's how guys talk to each other I
got news for you when two guys when they
think that you know when they especially
when they don't know that they're being
filmed secretly this is how two guys
talk to each other when they're pissed
off it's not a big deal you know this is
if you go harassing a guy especially if
he's out with his family you might say
that yeah I'm gonna throw you down stuff
he's not really gonna do it
it's just how guys talk why are we
pretending we don't know that why are
there men online pretending well I never
I would never talk to a person like that
this is so inappropriate let's shut up
that's that's really
I'm at the point now where I don't even
know how I can do this job anymore
because my main reaction to like 90% of
the controversies on either side now my
main reaction is just shut up already
you you please stop we all know but then
of cold is that I've been informed this
morning as I you know I was I was trying
to make this point on social media and
I've been informed as I always am that
if you don't join in the fake
performative outrage with conservatives
then you're a traitor to the cause this
is why we lose I was told I don't even
know who we is anymore
what do you mean we well and what are we
trying to win I don't even know anymore
all right let's go from a video I will
defend which you just saw to a video I
most definitely will not defend here I
hope we can all have agreement at least
on the right we can agree on this that
what you're about to see here is just
spica bleeding disgustingly despicable
however you want to put it we've
discussed plenty of times these crazy
gross demented drag queen story hours
which are now officially a thing there
are thing all across the dying Western
world men in dresses come to read
stories to children but sometimes they
do more than read stories I mean reading
the story is bad enough because they're
dressed up like like some cartoon some
some McCobb cartoon of a woman but
here's a here's a drag queen story our
that went much further than that
davonne library in the UK had one of
these events recently and a drag queen a
dude who goes by the name mama G which
is by the way totally normal right I
mean for for a guy to dress up like a
woman call himself mama Jean totally
normal now we can't criticize that god
forbid we suggest that there must be
something you know mentally out of sorts
with a part with a man who spends his
time we could never we could never
suggest such a thing it's totally normal
completed and
into one edge as a man to wanna dress up
as a woman to read stories to children
you know to say oh I want to dress up
like a woman so that I can be around
kids totally normal
nothing we could possibly say to
criticize that
so here's mama G he decided to take
things in an even creepier direction
than usual I warn you that what you're
about to witness is extremely disturbing
Michael likes to twerk now does anybody
in this room know how to twerk okay but
it's quite important to the story so I
will just give you a very quick all you
need to do is you just stand with your
feet shoulder-width apart like so okay
I'll show you other side cuz you get
better view W you crouch down into your
thumb sticking out yeah so there you go
that is yes that that that is exactly
what it looks like that is a man in a
dress at a library teaching young
children how to twerk I don't have to
explain probably so I won't go into much
detail explaining that twerking is a is
meant to be a sexually suggestive a very
sexually suggestive dance move that's
what it is and so this guy's is is
giving a demonstration to children and
to make it so much worse you know if if
this was just some crazy psycho lunatic
who ran into a room where they're a
bunch of kids and started twerking I
would be much less angry about it
because then I could say okay well this
is jet this is an isolated incident this
is this is a psycho let's get them off
the streets la
in a loony bin get him away from kids
and so then I could say that it's an
isolated thing it's one guy it's one guy
no crazy people are out there but this
is guys crazy we got him off the streets
now okay what makes this so infuriating
on such a deep level and so disgusting
it's not even the behavior of this guy
who clearly is mentally disturbed but
it's the parents who are sitting there
chuckling and laughing while a grown man
teaches there you know six and
seven-year-old kids had at work what
kind of a man imagine the the fathers
that are in that room just sitting there
laughing oh isn't that adorable
that grown man's teaching my
four-year-old daughter had its work this
is so charming imagine I can't imagine
it it well it's it's it's it's what's
happening so I don't need to imagine it
but I can't wrap my head around that
mentality as a father you know I'm just
waiting to see one of these drag queens
story hours or something like this is
happening and to have a you know a
father come in and pull a Chris Cuomo
not that I'm advocating violence but
I'll put it to you this way if I walked
into a room and there was a man in a
dress sexually harassing because that's
what this is sexually harassing my
six-year-old daughter I I wouldn't be
chuckling along I'll put it that way
okay I would respond in a way that would
not include applauding or expressing my
approval
I would I would express my disapproval
in a in a in a very unmistakable way
that's all I'm gonna say and but you
never see that instead you just see you
just see these henpecked dads and and
moms sitting around the sidelines
watching this habit it if this if
lived in a sane world that man who is
again sexually harassing sexually
abusing that to me that sexual abuse
you know III see that as sexual abuse
what you just witnessed there and if we
lived in a sane country even though this
wasn't this our country but if we lived
in a sane world that guy would be
arrested and all of the parents will be
arrested for at a minimum parental
neglect if not active parental abuse all
right um
on a related note The Daily wire if I
can pull it up has a story that is on
the website right now but read a little
bit of others too
so is that a teacher at a middle school
in northern Carroll California
triggered outrage from parents after he
handed out a gender identity graphic
allegedly to explain why he preferred to
be called
mx rather than mr. on the first day of
school so he wanted his you know prefix
to be rather than mr. M X how do you how
do you say M X so M R is mr. M X is what
what is that Mick Mixter mix is it mix
so stupid
Luis Davila Alvarado who teaches seventh
or eighth grade science at Denair middle
school used a gender unicorn graphic
from trans student education resources
to explain his choice of preferred
pronoun to a group of children between
the ages of 12 and 14 and then it goes
on from there he gave out this gave out
this this graphic now much to the credit
of the principal the principal happened
to come into the classroom while this
was going on and she took one look at
the epic gender unicorn graphic and she
said no no we're not doing this and she
had she had him take all the all of the
worksheets back so so good for her on
that but parents were upset as rightly
they should be let's take
look at this gender eunuch or the gender
unicorn is related to the gender bred
person which is a similarly creepy
worksheet that schools give out
sometimes so I'll put this up on the
screen so you can see here's the gender
unicorn and as you can see well there's
the gender unicorn right there teaching
us about all kinds of things about
gender and so you know you it's it's not
just that there's there isn't just one
spectrum okay as you can see here
there's like four different spectrums
there's the gender identity spectrum at
the top there
there's the gender expression spectrum
and then there's the spectrum of who
you're sexually attracted to and then
also who you're emotionally attracted to
so according to this and this is science
this was handed out in a science class
you could be a man who identifies as a
woman yet has a masculine gender
expression who is sexually attracted to
women but emotionally attracted to men
who identify as women like that's a
that's a that's a combination that's
possible yeah now we are we're
differentiating between sexually
attracted to it emotionally attracted to
it but this science this is what's this
is supposed to be science now listen
years in the future
hundreds of years from now thousands of
years when archaeologists of the future
are digging up the remains of our
pitiful civilization and they come
across something like this the gender
unicorn now of course this is on paper
so they probably wouldn't find it but
but if this was engraved on a stone
tablet somewhere and they came across
this they would look at that and
anthropologists would study this and
they would come to the conclusion that
this is part of this this is part of the
the the religious activity of some kind
of religious cult they would look at the
gender unicorn and all this stuff about
it
Spectrum's and gender identity and they
would assume that this was the you know
the worship activity of some kind of
cult and of course they would be correct
because that's what this is I mean this
is superstition this is religion and I
don't mean to use religion as a
pejorative but that's what this is and
you know there are crazy religions out
there not all religions are crazy in my
view but some are and this is a crazy
religion it's got nothing to do with
science
at all obviously there is no none of
this has any relationship at all with
biology or anything scientific or even
psychology it's the this is this is
superstition all the way through and
it's being taught at least in some
schools all right let's go to emails
Matt well show at gmail.com Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com
this is from Mackenzie says my husband
and I have been thinking about the whole
epstein situation and we have a theory
not sure if it's a conspiracy theory or
not but we think that Epstein is not
really dead but that he's in protective
custody there are a lot of people who
would want him dead and it just seems
too convenient that he had the chance to
kill himself I personally haven't heard
anything about seeing a body thoughts
yeah weekend's yeah I've seen this I
guess as we talked about yesterday
the sort of normal conspiracy theories
with with the Epstein case are totally
reasonable and justified
so to to wonder if maybe someone got to
him and staged it to look like a suicide
I don't think that's crazy at all I
think that that's certainly a
possibility but because the normal
conspiracy theories are normal then I
guess people we need to come up with you
know even crazier conspiracy theories
and that's where this comes from and no
offense I don't mean it as an insult but
this is the idea that he's still alive
and he was he was you know they shuffle
him off somewhere to hide him I've heard
two versions of this theory which is
it's a theory there's no evidence for
this theory McKenzie this is just
something that did you know you've and
others have sort of come up with in your
heads
so the two versions theory that I've
seen are okay maybe the powerful you
know people in the in the in his Epstein
sex cult maybe they found a way to
rescue him and bring him to some island
somewhere so there's that and the other
version is maybe it's the government did
this so that they could put him in
protective custody and hide him
somewhere
well while while they get information
from both of these things are it know
that that didn't happen again there's no
reason to think that there was a body
first of all in fact there's even
there's even there are even pictures of
his body out there if you really want to
go see him you can although I don't
recommend it so there was a body
there's no read there's no evidence for
this at all see anytime something
happens you can come up with a theory
you could come up with a million
theories that fit the facts as we know
them but just because you've invented a
theory that fits the facts that doesn't
mean that there's any there's any real
just if it doesn't mean that it's a
reasonable theory there's any reason to
actually think that I mean I could say
that Epstein was abducted by aliens that
fits the facts as we know them but that
doesn't mean that's a reasonable theory
or plausible and this just isn't
plausible at all because first of all
certainly the the people in Epstein's
sex cult which that is a real thing but
they would have no interest in keeping
Epstein alive they if they could get to
him they would kill him
they wouldn't they wouldn't bring him
off somewhere so he could live out the
rest of his days when though he's a
liability and so they want him dead the
idea did the idea that the government
would do this well it's just there's no
reason for them to do that they could
they could have easily kept him safe in
prison all they had to do was actually
keep an eye on him which they didn't do
so there's there there's no history of
our government faking someone's death so
that they can then keep them safe
somewhere in particular we have ways of
TV people say you can do it you just
have to actually put them in protective
custody and then protect them that's all
you got to do not to mention I mean I I
imagine Epstein's lawyers and and and
the lawyers of the other famous and rich
people out there would have a field day
with this
if if the government tries to use the
testimony of someone whose death they
faked there are all kinds of legal
problems there I would imagine because
that is not following proper legal
protocols and so I don't what what how
what good would the testimony be if it
came from someone who you claimed is
dead what are you going to say other we
had a seance and we resurrected his
ghost and that's how we got this
information so no there's no reason to
there's no reason to think that at all
from this is from KL says Matt you and
the rest of the Daily wire crew are
pathetic parroting the official line on
Epstein I'm disgusted and done with you
and the rest of them if I wanted
mainstream media talking points I know
where to get them so KL is not the I
actually got several emails like this
from people who are mad at me saying
that I was parroting the talking for the
official narrative or whatever yesterday
I don't I don't I don't even know where
this is coming from I said on the show
yesterday repeatedly that the so-called
conspiracy theories in this case are
perfectly plausible and justified now
the idea that he was that they faked his
death and that he's hiding out somewhere
on an island that I don't think is
plausible but there are the idea that
someone got to him and made it look like
a suicide sure it's possible perfectly
possible now as I said if Occam's razor
or the the mundane principle which I
just made up yesterday but I think it's
true that usually the most boring and
mundane explanation is correct most of
the time so according to that principle
probably he he did kill himself
but you know I don't know and my whole
point of the show I spent 15 minutes
yesterday talking about repeating myself
as I tend to do that there is there is
nothing at all crazy or unreasonable
about the so called conspiracy theories
so how that amounts to me parroting the
official narrative I have no idea if it
unless what you mean by that is that I
guess my fault is
just say that the conspiracy theories
are plausible I have to pretend that I
know that the conspiracy theories are
true so I didn't have certainty forgive
me for that how dare I
this is from Trevor says hi Matt have
been watching for a while I love your
show I'm 19 years old I've been a
Christian for about eight months now
congratulations Trevor I'm a part of a
wonderful Church at the college I attend
they are very traditional and
conservative in their conduct meaning
that they discourage watching movies
listening to music that may be too
explicit plus I have a pretty dark sense
of humor so I'm afraid to joke now about
how I've normally I'm afraid to joke how
I've normally done I understand it's
inappropriate in a church setting but
I'm not real sure about just in my life
outside of church I could help but think
about this when you mentioned Pulp
Fiction in your episode on Monday when I
was an atheist I always loved watching
Tarantino films or just watching any
movie that told a good story despite any
violence or profanity I also really
liked a lot of stand-up comedy I still
do lastly there's a lot of good music
out there that is not Christian music I
guess I'm just wondering if it's
acceptable to still watch extreme movies
listen to stand-up comedy even if it's
pretty profane and then listening to
good music that may be a little vulgar
at times it's not like this makes or
breaks my faith if I have to give it up
then so be it I understand that the
rationale of it but I just feel like a
lot of the good parts of life I'll be
missing out on I love to get your
thoughts on this
you're the best show on The Daily wire
keep up the great work there we go uh
Trevor yeah why I think first of all for
you to be doing an inventory of the way
you spend your time recreationally and
the music you listen to the movies you
watch to do that inventory is a good
thing and so you should be commended but
for that and we should all be doing that
inventory and yes it is it is there are
I think movies and shows out there that
are morally objectionable and there's
nothing really good that can come from
watching them and I don't say that like
I've seen plenty of that kind of stuff
myself in fact I was just talking about
that on the show yesterday which is what
you're referring to but
we should still challenge ourselves I
think and then same with music I mean
there's there's there's a lot of music
out there obviously that it's just pure
trash and garbage and all it does is
just drag you down into the gutter
mentally emotionally spiritually and so
again nothing really good can come from
it even if you kind of like the sound of
it whatever the music is it's still
garbage and so when it comes to that
kind you have to just use your own your
own judgment a judgment that you hone
over time as we all do as we grow and
mature so I think you have to it's good
to do that and if you and your judgement
if you know in your heart of hearts that
what you're watching is pure trash pure
junk then yeah you shouldn't watch it
doesn't mean you're gonna go to hell if
you do or that you're automatically a
bad Christian or something like that
it's just it's not helping it's not
edifying it's not helping you in your
own walk and so there's no really
there's just no good no reason to do it
other than you're you're just looking
for something to to watch which it
probably isn't a good enough reason so
there's that there's that part and
that's so that's the judgment call that
you have to make on the other side of it
though I definitely don't think Trevor
that just because you're a Christian now
you can't watch any secular shows or
movies you can't listen to secular music
like III don't think that now that
you're Christian all the music you
listen to has to be corny Christian
music not that all Christian music is
corny but a lot of it is and that every
show you watch has to be you know every
movie you watch has to be God's not dead
or something like that heaven is for
real no you don't have to limit yourself
to that there's in the so-called secular
world there's a lot of despite what you
may hear there's there's there's a lot
of good music there's a lot of good art
but you have to be discerning and I
think I guess especially just focusing
on on movies for a minute just as a for
example I think it's perfect
okay for a for a movie to deal with
difficult things to deal with you know
violence to have elements to the story
that are absurd disturbing whatever
scary you know
suspenseful that's that's fine
but I think what we have to ask
ourselves is what's the point is there a
point to this now if it's a movie that
it appears the only the only the only
point of the movie is just to drag you
down and just to depress you for the
sake of depressing you and the only
point the movies trying to make is that
there is no point in life and everything
is terrible just it's it's nihilistic
filth well then that's probably a movie
you don't need to watch but we were
talking about the Godfather so using the
Godfather as an example I mean the
Godfather is not what we would call a
Christian film and it's probably the
kind of movie that some Christians would
say oh that's total that's terribly
inappropriate for you shouldn't watch
that fight just watch the latest Kevin
Sorbo movie instead
no nothing against Kevin Sorbo I think I
think a godfather
yeah it's there's violence in that movie
there's vulgarity there's evil a lot of
bad stuff it's not for kids okay it's
definitely for adults but it's kind of a
Shakespearean tragedy and what I think
what the movie shows you if you watch at
least the first two it shows you this it
takes you a gives you a first a man you
know a basically virtuous good decent
man who's Michael Corleone a war hero in
the beginning of the first movie and it
shows step by step as he is dragged down
into evil and he sort of collapses in on
himself in this in his lust for power
and money and prestige and in the
meantime he loses everything else that's
important and that's real and that's
good in life and that's why I think the
last scene in in Godfather 2 is so
powerful because he's at the point know
for the first two movies he always
told himself that he was doing
everything for the family for the sake
of his family that's what this was all
really about even though he knew in the
back was mine this isn't really for the
families for him but then at that at the
end of the second movie he kills his own
brother so now the the idea that he's
doing it for the family is gone and so
he's just kind of standing there staring
out the window and it's in this nice
beautiful house but having lost
everything his wife hates him he's lost
his kids he's killed his brother every
one every all his friends are all dead
down he's got nothing he's got his
beautiful house he's got power he's got
nothing else and it was all for nothing
and then in the very last scene it
flashes back to this scene you know from
years before where he's sitting around
the dinner table with his family and and
you kind of see like that's that was
real that was good and he lost that so
anyway so that's a that's a good
positive message actually in a movie
like The Godfather which you can find in
those kinds of movies but I think you
just have to be discerning so so just a
long way of putting that all right let's
uh let's see it we have one more this is
from Carl says hi Matt one of my
favorite things you do is poke call this
is gonna be a long one maybe I should
say this one one of my favorite things
you do is poke holes and Christian
apologetic arguments I actually really
appreciate this coming from a Christian
like yourself
you helped me strengthen my arguments by
pointing out where the weaknesses are it
sometimes seems to me that Christian
apologists these days will throw any
argument against the wall I think a much
better strategy is to hone a few strong
arguments and really make them airtight
but in order to do that we must first
find its weak points I think you're good
at that so with all that said I believe
the fine-tuning argument is not the best
argument for God is if not the best
argument got at least a very good one
now can you put on your naysayer hat and
tell me where the problems are with that
argument also what do you consider to be
this the strongest arguments for God it
actually says the strangest arguments
but I assume that was a typo and you
meant to say strongest the strangest
arguments forgot okay this is what can I
do that can I do can I answer this
quickly I can't answer anything quickly
the fight I'll try to do briefly the
fine-tuning argument the fine-tuning
argument says that that there are
certain you know when you look at
physics there are certain universal
constants
the universe has been tuned has been
kind of programmed a certain way to make
life possible and that if you looked at
any of the if you look at the tuning the
certain the universal constants if any
of those were off by just the slightest
minuscule degree it would make life in
the universe impossible and so the
fine-tuning argument says well who to
tune it that way
the probability that it would just tune
itself that way on its own accidentally
is so minuscule that you could basically
say it's impossible and therefore you
need God and I think that's a strong
argument in fact Christopher Hitchens
who was no friend to theists said that
he thinks that's the strongest argument
for theism and that coming from an
atheist of his caliber I think is a
pretty is a pretty strong testament in
its favor so I think it's a good
argument my only criticism of it is I
think maybe it needs a different label
than fine-tuning the problem is to me it
seems like if the fine-tuning argument
is just a variation of the argument from
causation you know there's the first
cause argument going back to Thomas
Aquinas and before time's going saying
it's really on a very basic level like
this all had to start from some how this
all began somehow how did it begin yeah
at a certain point you need a first
cause you need an uncaused cause and
that uncaused cause would be God by
definition a cause that can cause other
things but does not itself need to be
caused is is God that's what God is God
is other things as well but he's also
that so it seems to me that the
fine-tuning argument is is basically an
extrapolation of that argument saying
that you know this this tuning of the
universe it couldn't have done it on its
own some thing or someone had to do it
so I think we need to frame it that way
the problem is when we say fine-tuning
it makes it sound like what we're
arguing is that you know the entire
universe is so remarkably hospitable to
life that we we know that God must exist
when that's not really the argument the
problem
when it's out if it sounds like you're
making that argument then the atheist
can say we'll hold on a second you know
ninety nine point nine nine nine nine
nine nine nine nine nine whatever
percent of the universe is lethal to
life the vast majority of the universe
pretty much you know essentially the
entire universe consists of radiation
filled vacuum that is lethal to life
nothing can live in it and if you were
to you know condense the entire universe
to scale down about the size of a house
the entire house will be filled with a
radiation filled vacuum and you'd have
one little atom one little proton that
would be earth and obviously if you
worked walked in if you were to walk
into a house where the entire thing
except for one little atom is is lethal
you would not say oh this house was was
built especially for life no you would
say the opposite you would say this
house is was built to kill me so that's
the problems that is that the the
universe is a very very very very very
big place and as far as we know all of
it is lethal to life except for the
little speck of dust that we're on so
now that that fact doesn't really debunk
the fine-tuning argument because that's
not what the fine-tuning argument is but
when you say fine-tuning it kind of
sounds like that's what you're saying so
maybe that's my plan maybe we just need
that's my only qualm with the
fine-tuning argument is that I think we
need a different name for it to make it
clear that we're not claiming that the
universe is completely hospitable to
life everywhere you go because that's
obviously not the case even earth is
mostly inhospitable to life you know the
the most of the earth is water you can't
live on it even on land a lot of the
earth is Arctic wasteland and deserts
where either you can't live or it's very
difficult to live so again we're not
really saying that we're just saying
that those constants at the beginning of
the universe the way the way the
universe was set up it was set up in
such a way that it was possible for
something like Earth to exist even if it
is one speck of dust in a in a giant
vacuum all right we will leave it there
thanks everybody for watching Godspeed
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know there
are plenty of problems
facing our country today but there's one
problem making all the other problems
worse it's a news media that has lost
its way in a vendetta against Trump it
is rapidly becoming a vendetta against
half the country we'll talk about it on
the Andrew Klavan show on Andrew Klavan